[Musica]
lui è d'oro non è un caso
il suo branco è composto da almeno 8 lug
hai un anno nero ed è bene tanti occhi
color ambra lo incontro in primavera al
tramonto e agile forte fiero è
bellissimo ma soprattutto è vitale è
vitale
già mi immagino fotografarlo mentre
corre alla testa del branco sulla neve
nel prossimo inverno
se avremo l'inverno e se avremo la neve
quella corsa comunque zorro non la farà
mai è stato trovato alcune settimane fa
privo di vita lungo le rive di un canale
molto probabilmente avvelenato di lui
non mi rimarranno solo le immagini
scattate ma una fortissima anche se
malinconica emozione
continuo però a chiedermi avrei potuto
fare qualcosa posso ancora fare qualcosa
qual è il ruolo del fotografo di natura
il suo compito non si esaurisce nel
ritrarre la bellezza attraverso
l'obiettivo ma deve trasmettere un
messaggio scuotere gli animi prendendosi
cura di ciò che ritrae il fotografo
alimentasi la propria passione ma la
traduce in impegno
un impegno che ci deve riguardare tutti
quanti deve diventare gesto di cura
quotidiana
solo così possiamo sperare di arginare i
devastanti effetti degli attuali
cambiamenti climatici mostrare la
meraviglia l'incanto della natura è un
modo per ricordarci di difenderla come
si difende il bene più prezioso che una
volta perduto non saremo più in grado di
recuperare mostrare la bellezza della
natura è anche il mio modo per indicare
a tutti quello che stiamo perdendo
vorrei ora farvi vedere alcune mie
fotografie
[Applauso]
[Musica]
si no
spesso il prendersi cura nasce da una
passione che solo pochi pochissimi sono
riusciti a trasformare nella missione
della loro vita penso ai medici in prima
linea durante i conflitti ai missionari
come il mio amico gabriele nei luoghi
più remoti della terra ma anche agli
attivisti ambientalisti la passione per
la natura occupa i miei primi ricordi ci
sono immagini che sono impresse nella
mia mente come se fossero fotografie in
un album
penso alla lepre che attraversa
all'improvviso agli occhi del bambino a
l'aquila che si libra sulle guglie
dolomitiche durante una passeggiata
estiva a ogni rifiorire della primavera
vissuta sempre come un incanto come una
magia agli inizi delle mie esperienze
la ricerca di emozioni l'inseguimento
dell'attimo fotografico perfetto
l'immersione solitaria nella natura
devo ammettere che erano la ragione
esclusiva del mio lavoro
poi l'incontro con persone a stretto
contatto con la natura con culture
già allora molto attente a problematiche
ambientali
mi ha fatto riflettere in definitiva il
fotografo di natura a disposizione tanto
tempo nei momenti nei lunghi
avvicinamenti e soprattutto durante i
lunghissimi appostamenti si contempla la
bellezza si ascoltano i suoni ma si
impara ad ascoltare anche i silenzi e
questo ci porta a riflettere ad
ascoltarsi in profondità
sono arrivato a capire che l'emozione la
passione da sole non sono sufficienti
il mondo il momento contemplativo non
basta bisogna agire non possiamo
rimanere indifferenti davanti a quello
che sta avvenendo al nostro pianeta
ho iniziato così
contare i miei progetti e le mie
esperienze a mostrare l'estrema
fragilità della bellezza unica che è il
nostro pianeta
l'ho fatto nei miei libri fotografici
l'ho fatto durante le presentazioni
delle mie mostre e in qualunque
occasione
ho iniziato a ideare ea divulgare
progetti volti a sensibilizzare la gente
a questo argomento
in fondo il fotografo di natura è un
ladro di luce come tale io cerco di
rubare alla natura dei degli attimi
irripetibili in luoghi che sono spesso
inaccessibili
la ragione di questo furto però è poter
mostrare a tutti il prezioso bottino
condividere momenti che credo
appartengano a tutti
in fondo zorro adesso è un po anche il
vostro lupo
vorrei farvi vedere altre immagini
[Musica]
[Applauso]
la passione per i ghiacci il forte senso
per la neve sono entrati in me leggendo
da bambino
le avventure di bach di zanna bianca gli
eroi di jack london
il richiamo della foresta mi ha portato
sempre più a nord oltre il circolo
polare artico però anno dopo anno ho
potuto constatare che l'estate erano
sempre più lunghe sempre più calde gli
inverni sempre più brevi ho attraversato
la lapponia sotto bufere di neve in auto
da solo ho atteso giorni e giorni
l'arrivo dei lupi in fragili capanni
nella foresta russa ho camminato anche
durante tormente per ore in norvegia
alla ricerca del buon muschiato
fotografando anche a meno 40 gradi o in
seguito le orche marine lungo le coste
su barche che riuscivano solo a stento
per pochi attimi ad affiancarle certo io
cercavo il freddo e la neve li ho
trovati
ma ogni anno sempre più a nord sempre
più in alto sulle montagne questa
passione per i ghiacci mi accompagna da
sempre
adesso però si traduce in impegno prima
era solo emozione sto organizzando una
spedizione alle isole svalbard per
verificare la condizione dei ghiacci la
situazione dei ghiacci per sentire dalla
voce delle persone
cosa è cambiato nel loro modo di vivere
negli ultimi anni ma anche o forse
soprattutto per cercare l'orso bianco
l'animale che più spesso è messo a
rischio la cui sopravvivenza è più a
rischio
dallo scioglimento dei viaggi dai primi
contatti che ho avuto ho potuto
apprendere che ogni anno la banchisa si
forma sempre più tardi in autunno il
disgelo avviene sempre prima
quindi un inverno sempre più breve
sempre meno possibilità per l'orso
bianco una spedizione di questo genere è
molto impegnativa soprattutto da un
punto di vista economico la ricerca di
partners di un sostegno e difficile
difficilissima ma non impossibile
spesso come capita durante le mie
spedizioni fotografiche la soluzione la
meta sono nascoste dietro a uno degli
ultimi secoli la condizione necessaria è
quella di non demoralizzarsi di non
scoraggiarsi e io non lo faccio non lo
faccio mai anche perché le sorprese sono
sempre dietro l'angolo
ho conosciuto un imprenditore veramente
sensibile a queste tematiche
dialogando con lui ho appreso che
tramite la sua fondazione la giancarlo
paterlini onlus ha creato una scuola per
bambini in africa
la new bambini school a chicca in kenya
pensate che ogni giorno sei autobus da
50 posti l'uno prendono i bambini li
portano a scuola dando loro futuro
questa scuola ha oggi 800 bambini 550
purtroppo sono orfani per loro non è
solo scuola e la loro casa vivono lì
ecco questo penso che sia un esempio
straordinario eclatante di una persona
che è riuscita a trasformare una
passione in una missione
siccome le grandi idee sono contagiose
non è probabilmente il periodo adatto
per parlare di contagi
però sinceramente non mi viene in mente
un termine più bello da affiancare la
parola idee dialogando e abbiamo deciso
di inviare molte coppie e l'abbiamo
fatto nel mio ultimo libro sulle aurore
boreali ai bambini è sicuramente se
riuscirò a realizzare il libro sull'orso
bianco ciascun bambino avrà una coppia
di questo libro
cercheremo di portare nella terra del
sole la neve è connessa l'idea che
appartenendo tutti allo stesso pianeta
dobbiamo difenderlo in definitiva siamo
le nostre scelte ma siamo anche le
persone che abbiamo incontrato quelle
che incontreremo
vorrei adesso salutarvi
anzi un appello
coltiviamo le nostre passioni
mescoliamo le alle passioni degli altri
in un impegno costruttivo
superiamo il momento meramente egoistico
e trasformiamolo in un gesto in impegno
il nostro impegno anche se piccolo anche
se minimo unito a quello degli altri
avrà una forza inarrestabile
vorrei ora salutarvi con un'immagine a
me cara
amo molto le montagne anche in
condizioni estreme in inverno durante
forti nevicate
spesso parto per salire su una qualche
cima la lieve trasforma il paesaggio la
modella e realizza sugli anni i rami
degli alberi dei ricami fragili di
ghiaccio e di neve fragili perché al
primo contatto la neve cade e la magia
svanisce mentre salgo vorrei essere
incorporeo senza peso per non lasciare
tracce
naturalmente questo non è possibile però
ho imparato nel corso degli anni ad
evitare il contatto coi rami anche
compiendo delle buffe contorsioni è
giusto godere dell'incanto ma abbiamo il
dovere di lasciarlo perché ci sia
segue preservarlo per chi verrà dopo di
noi
[Applauso]